this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I don't actually think that the future
of warfare is going to be in genetically
enhanced soldiers like Captain America
the the ethics of warfare the part of
warfare today that's becoming
problematic is almost exactly the
opposite and that is people sitting in a
chair in Nevada in front of computer
screens running drones on the other side
of the world with the capacity to kill
people without any risk whatsoever to
the human soldier running it or at least
without any direct risk and that to me
is a deeply ethically problematic issue
when you make killing so easy and when
you remove the person so far from the
site of the killing and when people no
longer see the consequences of their
action when you have to run up to
another person and stab them with a
bayonet there's no question what you've
just done and there's no question about
what the consequences of what you've
just done is on the other hand when
you're sitting somewhere else and you
drop a bomb off a drone and you mean
maybe you don't even the drone doesn't
even stay around to see if the bomb hit
the target because it's got something
else to do you've really created a kind
of warfare or human connection to the
destruction of warfare has been removed
it's such a great degree that you begin
to wonder about whether some of the
natural moderating factors the human
desire not to cause wanton destruction
even though we do it all the time
whether
the kind of consideration that we give
before we kill someone when we know the
consequences of our actions will people
drop the bomb rather than not dropping
the bomb because the the sense of having
killed people has now become so abstract
those are real questions about the
future of warfare and if this develops
to a point where lots of warfare is
conducted that way where our enemy is
sitting in their bunkers in front of
computer screens and we're sitting and
our bunkers in front of computer screens
what that really means of course is that
the soldiers who are actually doing the
fighting will be instead of the least
protected people that is the people in
the streets of Baghdad who are going to
who the IEDs gonna hit they're gonna be
the most protected people sitting in
some bunker deep underground somewhere
so who are the bombs gonna hit so this
kind of a strategy actually ends up
protecting soldiers more and exposing
civilians more than even the way warfare
is being done now so in a sense Captain
America is a nostalgic figure of a time
when soldiers actually did the fighting
and when enhancing the soldier him or
herself though it wasn't her seemed to
be the best way to improve combat now
the worry is exactly the opposite that
the soldier in some sense becomes
irrelevant that or at least the the
actual physical capability of the
soldier gender becomes irrelevant a
woman can sit in front of that screen
and press the buttons with as much skill
as a man so when you don't need the
physicality of combat you know a woman's
role can be equal to a man's without any
concerns about those kinds of things and
it's going in it will change the nature
of warfare and raise a new kind of
ethical calculus about the way in which
warfare is conducted
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University